لم ينالوا فرصه الانقاذ من الزلزال لكنهم
لم يحظوا ايضا بطقوس الانتشار والدفن فبعد
مرور خمسه اسابيع على الكارثه عائله سوريه
وتركيا لا تزال تنتظر جثث اقاربها دون
جدوى هؤلاء يحاولون حل اللغز الاصعب في
كوارث كهذه اين المفقودين حيث اكدت محاميه
سوريه عدم قدرتها على ايجاد والدها في اي
مكان بالعالم لا تحت الانقاض ولا
بالمستشفيات السلطات بالبلدين قدمت
معلومات شحيحه حول عدد الاشخاص المفقودين
لكن استاذا بالطب الشرعي رجح فقدان نحو
1500 شخص في تركيا وحدها طرق عده تقف وراء
فقدان اشخاص اولها حدوث فوضى اوليه حيث
يرسل المصابون لمستشفيات بعيده وربما
ماتوا دون علم اقاربهم ودفنوا كجثث مجهوله
الهويه على عجل وفي هذه الحاله قد تساعد
البصمات واختبارات الحمض النووي والصور
الفوتوغرافيه بمحاوله ربط الجثث المجهوله
الهويه طبعا باقاربها وبالفعل حصلت بعض
المطابقات اما اخرون فربما احترقوا بسبب
النيران او نقلوا كبقايا بعيدا عند ازاله
الانقاض عن طريق الخطا
[موسيقى]